what's going on guys
Disney's latest film Moana it hits
theaters next week and I had the chance
to have a sneak peek of the movie and
talked to its cast and filmmakers about
all things Disney included in that group
is mr. Dwayne the rock Johnson old
friend of the show new friend of mine
let's check it out and watch The Rock
become some of your favorite classic
Disney characters so our screen junkies
fans they love Dwayne the rock Johnson
as I love them yes and they love Disney
and we asked them if you could see
Dwayne uh do any characters from any
iconic Disney films or give us his spin
what would your top ones be and we have
a couple of things here guys wondering
if you might be able to yeah just give
us your take so buzz like Buzz Lightyear
to infinity my take remember it's my
interpretation that was intense I love
it
if you could have um created songs for
one Disney film what would you have what
film would it have been oh uh that's
really hard because I really I wouldn't
want to touch most of the scores
actually you know what I just always
wanted to be a newsie I would want to
write a new song but I just want to be
one of the Newsies so I gotta ask I'm
sure everyone's asked about working with
Dwayne the rock Johnson it deserves its
own question yeah if you could cast him
as any classic Disney character would
you thankful which think guest on I
think he'd make a good guest on but uh I
think I've already done the live-action
version so it's too late if you think of
someone who's was larger than life but
also has a bit of an ego okay so there's
a little scene I will read opposite I
will be Belle if you'll like okay good
so this is the day that your dreams come
true what do you know about my dreams
Gaston listen Oh
again it's my interpretation guys here
picture this a rustic hunting lodge my
latest kill roasting on the fire and my
little wife massaging my feet while the
little ones play on the floor with the
dogs we'll halves will wait I'm not
finished yet
woman this is all kinds of ávila we'll
have six or seven strapping boys
like me oh my like that yes that was
amazing yes there are rumors around that
people tried to sneak little things into
Aladdin little mermaid any care to
comment on any of the hidden I don't in
Milan
no no I'm specifically only gonna make
the Monson mermaid as well they that
they are not true even though people
will will testify and I will say only
this the minister had nabi millions he
had not been and on the other front on a
Len there was this rumor that somehow he
said something I didn't say and he
actually asked out my gir we had him at
live some stuff and he's saying good
tiger take off scat go and some of that
turns into something about teenagers
unclosed that was not really ever what
he said but he said good tiger take off
scat go on good take down all right
let's do genie from Aladdin Oh wonderful
there we go
three wishes and ixnay on the wishing
for more wishes that's it
three uno dos tres no substitutions
exchanges or what they call refunds
again it's my interpretation absolute
right I feel it I think there is no part
that you couldn't play ah that's true is
there any way we could do a little
freestyling about this obvious person to
ask can I make up a rap and will you
judge it yeah sure okay give me a topic
to rap about um why people should see
mallanna um okay people should see Moana
do you wanna you should
cuz it's good Dwayne the rock oh he does
the talk and he walks the walk mallanna
she's a little boss oh man she's coming
out with it cuz she's coming at you with
that sauce and the weather she keeps it
together she finds the heart of the
ocean and things are in motion very good
Thank You Len a a very win for a very
good from lin-manuel miranda I will take
it oh that's all day long well that was
a good time don't forget Disney's Moana
hits theaters Wednesday November 23rd
check it out also we'd like to know
what's your face
Ritt Disney film of all time and here's
another question if they were gonna do a
live-action reboot of one of these
Disney films what actor would you want
to see play what role tell us in the
comments love to hear your thoughts I
want to thank you for watching screen
junkies I'm Hal Rudnick hit me up on
Twitter bye-bye if you love the rock and
who doesn't be sure to check out more
videos featuring him right here on
screen junkies news go ahead it works
with your phone and everything